yeah hello and welcome to this video
darling a new session here a couple of
blitz games against a lot you know that
I could set up i think it is new away it
could have clothes that one so probably
get some ratty system memory sound
opening trip to e6 hmm that's not
particularly common once you have played
be six right c6 very ambitious set up
against to fianchetto normally you
cannot put the knight on c6 as taking
night a forms put so much pressure on
the center but will team 94-92
immediately trades the active p the lens
e5 remains weak
usually you have to play Knight bd7 and
Bishop d7 to support the ending pawns
better we'll see how problematic is in
fact is but it definitely it's not easy
for black hair whoopee one is also going
to ask some questions about the d5 pawn
[Music]
so not quite sure what his next move is
yeah so here I was thinking would be one
just attack d5
so if i take take on d5 why do we have
anything better at bishop's III as well
alpha group t7 at the answer it should
be good right when I one day though if I
should insert we should see three
pushing back first and only then take
125 as both got em both lines to
extremely good I always can enter on the
same drank at the end leading to a very
good ending
yeah now taking on these three I guess
the end there's always look to the sound
can i donate for is not not ideal but
still probably bishop to have sex I
don't see any other good square
you know very likely f8 maybe a fader
[Music]
okay so i think i probably will take
dominating here the seventh rank is
pretty good night be 67 things like that
is that they are annoying sound Ranga
spree week maybe he tries something like
Luke c6 trying to prevent that
maybe some counter-attack heal
yeah but i think i'm also reasonably
quick here 97 I mean I threatening to
take two pawns with check f6 and h7 it
can take with the group here I know then
I have who care for so okay okay okay
phone I'll ok 82 and my technical say it
wasn't good not at all and then and he
get to the second rank
yeah absolutely no winning show example
unfortunately
g four years enough before that is it
draws its lucky okay too much much else
okay what what time warning unbelievable
a mate and that's point this is this is
worse right after this game the way the
game went yeah okay so so how do i how
do I kill this off it's really in a
really bad position while the engine
doesn't agree I don't believe that this
is supposed to be okay for black how is
that possible I mean I'm much better
placed against those be pawns how can
that not be in advance
very strange it should be formed amazing
so what what did i do local then what is
wrong does this must be good for why
it's a plane no very surprising radio k
the engine has no depth to speak about
but still night you want a stronger I t2
is completely normal running you night
before supposed to be okay well okay
queen 85 then there's a mistake this is
what the engine does and this one okay
maybe there is just tech text ya like
he's just about enough have enough
activity gym to trade stuff down that
that's possible like this and here black
summer holds yeah possible that he can
somehow sec upon and not not be so so
much so much worse I should really
windows ending it looks so pretty awful
and like the six immediately maybe I
like 25 wins again and here you have
very little chances to win with the
actor hoop or serve something who cares
to hear I of course here I was better I
mean it's cyllage reward
king of three immediately okay
threatening made yeah I sure thought
about this a little bit i mean i've got
more time on the clock and I mean okay I
actually did not see that King g4 is
actually possible that he's saving the
skin and bone ending like this little
control here which is the drone Yahoo
via can I can be no time of course for
them and as also not the way I'm doing
it huh that's disappointing after this
this opening ok guys thanks for watching